the sounds of the city
noise is a reality of daily urban life
and as canada's population grows so too
does the relentless noise
despite the belief that it's something
we get used to the science tells a
different story
you know you can't turn your ears off
your body's still listening you're still
hearing these things and it's still
activating our nervous system
tor oyamo is one of the leading noise
researchers in canada he says the health
effects of noise pollution can be
significant when you're exposed to or
hear a sound that you don't want to hear
so a noise
there it tends to stress you out and
that that elicits a physiological
reaction in our bodies which then can
manifest in a lot of different outcomes
such as heart disease cardiovascular
disease metabolic diseases like diabetes
the short-term impacts of noise include
stress and sleep deprivation but experts
say the most significant health effects
happen over years and decades
they can be chronic and serious
tor was the lead researcher of a study
that found close to 90 percent of people
in toronto were exposed to daytime noise
levels that exceeded the world health
organization's recommendations of 55
decibels so it's you know significant
concern over time over you know months
and years that really starts to
potentially
lead to more severe effects
traffic noise is a 24-hour reality for
toronto resident silk and joseph
when is the noise at its loudest and
what do you do at home to keep out the
sound i would definitely say around the
rush hour period because you know you
have people leaving work you have the
construction men who are just done their
work for the day as well so you have
their trucks rolling out plus the
commuters going back home
like other big city residents silken
lives in a condo overlooking a busy
highway in her case that's an eight lane
expressway along toronto's lakefront
just enjoying a nice
evening on my balcony
i can hear
all the roaring traffic of toronto
of the highway and just the surrounding
streets really
canadian cities are loud and that is in
large measure because of cars
in toronto cars and traffic account for
about 60 percent of the noise
even silken's local park is right next
to the freeway i can't escape from it i
find and especially because
my condo community like the entire
area that i live in just backs onto the
gardener so
it's literally
constant noise it's like having a
highway in your backyard what impact
does all that noise have on your health
so i definitely feel a lot less rested
so i'm not getting
as sound of asleep as i'm used to i'm
very much alert my mind is very much on
and so now i have to shut everything
else out and force myself to go back to
sleep
it's now
[Music]
4 20 in the morning
[Music]
gotta love living in the city
waking up in a panic is never fun
whether i think the outside noise is
coming from inside my apartment it's
just a matter of that alertness that you
don't even get to escape from
it's hard for silken to escape it
even her job as a school bus driver is
constantly noisy on the road and when
the kids are on board so you leave home
from one noisy environment to go to work
at another noisy environment driving a
school bus what's that like
it's definitely taxing
i love what i do but i feel like it's
literally out of the frying pan and into
the oil because i'm in one noise and i'm
into another and then i feel like i
don't get that break in between it's
definitely taxing
[Applause]
so this is a great example of a really
loud urban setting where are we right
now
we're at the intersection of oxford and
wonderland road in london ontario
we met with tour in london like many
canadian cities it has wide roadways
often right next to homes
you can see as cars are passing by
70 69.
see that traffic
whoa that brought that up to a 90. yeah
yeah
sound is measured in decibels health
impacts can start above 50 decibels
on the monitor tour uses to study noise
this intersection is reading above 70
decibels
[Applause]
it's actually a number at which we know
hearing damage can start occurring so if
you're exposed to this
sound level
for an extended period of time you know
eight hours a day
the prolonged exposure to loud noise is
concerning and not everyone is exposed
in the same way so is there significant
disparities when it comes to noise level
depending on someone's income level we
do see a trend the higher income areas
tend to have lower
noise exposures
homes near airports or rail yards or
highways
and not everyone can afford to move away
to escape the noise
what is the biggest source of noise
pollution in our cities
it's traffic road traffic just because
traffic is so widespread
[Applause]
so many people
are exposed to it
and again it's
it is the loudest source
canadian cities have noise bylaws and
there are strategies to reduce noise
like sound walls but to create a
substantial shift cities would have to
become more creative
to see what can be done you need to go
to barcelona
in the 1980s the city was choked by
noisy gas guzzlers and plenty of smog
even today it's still noisy in parts of
the city
57 percent of the population live with
noise exposure that the who considers
too much we've got a big problem of
noise we've got a big problem of
pollution air pollution
and we've got also a big problem of co2
emissions sylvia casseron martos is
deputy chief architect for the barcelona
city council and a cycling advocate she
says around 130 people die in the city
every year from cardiovascular issues
related to noise to reduce the noise
they've created areas of the city known
as superblocks here's how the
superblocks work
take this nine square block radius
normally traffic flows freely but within
the super blocks the speed limit is
reduced to 10 kilometers per hour and
cars have to divert around the area
rather than pass right through it
the result the streets have become more
open pedestrian friendly pleasant
and quiet
the changes were not easy at first some
residents defended their right to drive
through and were resistant to the loss
of car movement
but since the change happened these
areas are now more vibrant the the
community
is really changing because people feel
more attached to the to their
neighborhood to their city
when they when they enjoy walking when
they enjoy playing in the streets
it's just a question of priorities and
political will
sounds like this yeah
all day
all day back in toronto silken wishes
her city could be quieter the noise is
having an impact on her sleep and stress
levels exactly what experts say is
concerning
like i'm always hyper aware which
definitely triggers some form of anxiety
and some stress as well
experts know what's at risk and hope
there's the political will to make
cities and residents safer from the
chronically high levels of noise what we
want to do then really is reduce the
proportion of people that exceed those
levels in a city one one city at a time
one street at a time i can't tell you
the last time i've heard a bird in the
city
i wish i could hear silence i wish i
could just
not hear anything for a little bit and
just hear the life around me